[MUSIC PLAYING]
DEBI CABRERA: Do you
use a service mesh
and worry about compliance?
Learn how to use a private
certificate authority
to improve security, strengthen
compliance, and reduce
headaches.
Today, we'll learn about
Certificate Authority Service,
its integration with
Anthos Service Mesh,
and how they work together
to achieve your goals.
Anthos Service Mesh,
or ASM, security
helps you mitigate
insider threats
and reduce the risk
of a data breach
by ensuring that
all communications
between workloads are encrypted,
mutually authenticated,
and authorized, leveraging
industry standards, like Mutual
TLS, or MTLS for short.
ASM offers a slew of
security benefits.
It mitigates risk of replay
or impersonation attacks
that use stolen credentials,
ensures encryption in transit,
mitigates the risk of user data
breach within your production
network by ensuring that only
authorized clients can access
a service, and identifies
which clients--
access to service
with sensitive data.
Anthos Service Mesh includes a
Google-managed, multiregional
private certificate
authority, Mesh CA,
for issuing
certificates for MTLS.
But what do you do if you
need to back your CA signing
keys in a Google-managed HSN, or
in a highly regulated industry
and are subject to compliance,
or need flexibility
with your on-prem route to move
between clouds without being
tied to a specific provider?
Cue Certificate
Authority Service,
which can replace Mesh CA.
CAS is a highly available,
scalable service
that enables you to simplify,
automate and customize
the deployment, management, and
security of private Certificate
Authorities, or CAs.
It allows you to converge all
of your certifications and CAs
into a single management
pane to reduce your risk
and increase the control and
visibility over the operations
in your org.
Do you have a situation
where one team handles
all the certifications
or where certifications
can be made without appropriate
visibility for security
and compliance teams?
CAS removes the bottlenecks
and increases visibility,
and therefore security,
by providing guardrails.
CAS does this by defining
granular access controls
and virtual security parameters,
defining per user group
insurance policy and baseline
certificate extensions,
storing CA keys in Cloud HSM--
which is FIPS 140-2 Level
3-validated and can help
achieve various
compliance certifications,
like FedRAMP and SOC--
and by obtaining logs
and gaining visibility
into who did what, when, and
where with Cloud audit logs.
Additionally, it's
configured by you,
giving you control over
your infrastructure.
To recap, CAS allows
you to converge
all of your
certifications and CAs
into a single management pane.
It reduces your risk
by providing guardrails
for usage and increases
the control and visibility
over operations in your
org while simultaneously
removing bottlenecks, allowing
for increased efficiency.
And you can easily install
it right in the command line.
To install Certificate Authority
Service with Anthos Service
Mesh, and if you want to learn
how to create a certificate
authority, check out the
links in the description
for a helpful video
and documentation.
[MUSIC PLAYING]